mich hat heute die Pressekonferenz
unseres Wirtschaftsministers Robert
Habeck bewegt hören wir doch einmal rein
diejenigen die sich mit der Materie
intensiver beschäftigt haben wissen oder
haben vielleicht schon mal gehört dass
planmäßig Ende des Jahres zwei
Braunkohlekraftwerke von RWE jeweils 600
Megawatt stark aus dem Betrieb hätten
gehen sollen hätten gehen sollen weil
wir ihn heute eine Vereinbarung
vorstellen möchten dass diese
Braunkohlekraftwerke bis Ende März 24 am
Netz bleiben sollen
das ist eine spannende Entwicklung der
noch vor einem halben Jahr war
Deutschland mittendrin im Cola Ausstieg
jetzt kann die schmutzigen
Stromproduzenten also zurück ans Netz
aber selbstverständlicher das Comeback
eine Haltbarkeitsdauer für
Steinkohlekraftwerke gilt es maximal bis
Ende März 2024 für Braunkohle soll die
Rückkehr zunächst bis zum 30 Juni 2023
befristet sein ich frage mich und sie
vielleicht zu Hause auch warum reagiert
die Politik erneut so spät und
begrenzend es war doch aus der
Industrien in den vergangenen Monaten
wiederholt die Kritik geäußert worden
dass die wieder in Betriebnahme Alter
Kohlekraftwerke zu langsam geschehe und
dementsprechend meine erste Frage an die
Fürstin mal ganz platt gefragt ist
Robert Habeck eine lahme Schnecke
also man spricht ja nicht schlecht über
andere Leute aber natürlich wäre es
besser wenn wir Kernkraftwerke hätten
weil die sind wesentlich
umweltfreundlicher aber ich habe das
Gefühl dass das die ganze Debatte
Ideologie geleitet wird und nicht
Tatsachen geleitet braun und überhaupt
Kohle ist sehr schädlich für die Umwelt
sehr schädlich ist auch wenn man große
dieselschiffe über den Ozean schippert
um uns Flüssiggas zu verkaufen ist auch
nicht ideal die windkraftfeder
verschandeln ganz Deutschland aber es
ist eben Ideologie und nicht
tatsachenbasiert das Beste für die
Umwelt sind die modernen
Atomkraftwerke die auch nicht die kann
man nicht mit Tschernobyl vergleichen
das sind ganz neue Generation es gibt ja
mittlerweile schon kleine Kraftwerke für
jeden zu Hause also die Technologie ist
da leider nicht von Deutschland
ausgegangen in Deutschland war es ja
verboten auch darüber zu forschen aber
die Amerikaner und die Chinesen haben
fleißig weiter gemacht und es gibt ja
schon sehr sehr gute Lösungen haben Sie
Verständnis dass er Habeck so lange
gezögert hat überhaupt Atomkraftwerke
länger laufen zu lassen sehr gut das
sind die Grünen die Grünen die haben das
ist wie eine Religion also das ist die
glauben einfach und das ist das ist der
Glaube wichtiger als die Tatsache da
muss die Hose oben halten ohne
Hosenträger auch wenn sie zu groß ist
einfach der Glaube bedeutet die Hose
hält oben auch wenn ich eigentlich
Hosenträger bräuchte wie gefährlich sind
denn die Grünen für unsere Wirtschaft ja
brandgefährlich die Grünen haben uns in
einem die Energiewende war wahnsinnig
ist hat die Menschen verarmt die
Energiewende hat den den Menschen allen
Reich und Arm das gilt nur so seit 20 30
Jahren aus der Tasche gezogen und den
fehl investiert das Geld könnte man also
wie gesagt dass diese ganze die ganze
Energiewende ist gescheitert das sieht
man jetzt aber was das gekostet hat und
die Leute zu Verantwortung ziehen das
müsste man machen wird aber nicht
gemacht Herr Knabe würden sie der
Fürstin zustimmen ja ich kann das nur
unterstreichen ich habe mich ja lange
mit der DDR beschäftigt um auch ständig
in die Wirtschaft hinein gefunkt hat
alles verstanden hat die Preise
künstlich subventioniert oder auch
aufgesetzt für Luxus sogenannte
Luxusgüter und wo das geendet hat das
wissen wir alle die DDR war Bankrott
1989 und ich habe gerade in den letzten
Tagen noch mal ein Buch zur Hand
genommen von Rolf Hinrich der
vormundschaftliche Staat heißt das
sonder beschreibt ja wozu diese
ständigen ideologischen politischen
Eingriffe auf die Wirtschaft und auch
auf die Gesellschaft führt führen und
nämlich zum zur Ineffektivität und und
der träumt dann quasi davon das Land zu
befreien von dieser Plan Bürokratie von
dieser Politikerkaste und das ist dann
auch eingetreten im Herbst 89 sie sind
eingestiegen mit dem ddr-vergleich das
ist ja immer ein relativ gefährlicher in
Deutschland
da sind wir denn schon in einer
Planwirtschaft also in der
Energiepolitik ziemlich nah weil das ist
keine freie Marktwirtschaft wo Waren
angeboten werden und Käufer diese waren
dann kaufen und sich auf diese Weise der
Preis ein Bild sondern das ist zur
massiv staatlich durchsteuert durch eben
festgesetzte Steuern die auf die auf den
Energieverbrauch gelegt werden jetzt
gibt es plötzlich wieder eine Subvention
da wird Gas plötzlich viel billiger als
es wirklich kostet und dann geht das
sogar so weit dass man den Leuten nachts
die Heizung ausdreht das hat sich nicht
mal die DDR getraut sie waren ja mal
Berater auch der grün was würden Sie
denn den Grünen heute raten ja da kann
ich dir 14 nur zustimmen wirklich
pragmatisch zu entscheiden nicht
ideologisch und auch die Wirtschaft mal
machen lassen man muss da nicht in
Deutschland gibt es so diese Tendenz für
alle Probleme die man hat ist der Staat
verantwortlich und das haben die
Politiker so verinnerlicht dass sie auch
selbst dieses immer wieder jetzt
füttern sozusagen diese
Erwartungshaltung wenn der Herr Scholz
da keiner bleibt allein das ist ein
Anspruch den kann er gar nicht erfüllen
das ist absurd und das Problem was
daraus auch noch folgt ist wenn die
Politiker sagen wir sind für alles
verantwortlich und müssen alle Probleme
lösen dann sagen die Bürger auch
irgendwann mal na dann haut doch ab ihr
löst ja die Probleme nicht und das ist
die Erfahrung der DDR Herr Trabert gehen
sie mit rein ja in die Grünen Kritik
oder haben Sie einen anderen Ansatzpunkt
absolut nicht also ich finde das ist
sehr undifferenziert was gesagt wird ein
harter Vorwurf direkt unifferenziert das
ist auch und differenziert in meinen
Augen die erneuerbaren Energien das ist
die Zukunft da müssen wir investieren da
hat man viele Fehler in der
Vergangenheit gemacht man hat zu wenig
in erneuerbare Energien
investiert die Atomkraft ist nicht die
Lösung wir wissen dass Atomkraftwerke
weiterhin gefährlich sind
da hat man die Technik noch nicht bis
ins Letzte und der Kontrolle man hat das
jetzt in Frankreich gesehen wo die
Flüsse überhitzt waren wo man das wo man
gar nicht mehr die Brennstäbe
entsprechend Abkühlen konnte das ist
nicht die Zukunft und ich finde es
wirklich fatal jetzt wieder Rolle
rückwärts in die Vergangenheit nein der
Weg muss mehr in Windkraft in
Sonnenenergie in viele andere
erneuerbare Energien gehen alles andere
wird zu einer Umweltverschmutzung weiter
beitragen der Klimawandel den wir jetzt
schon haben wird damit auch unterstützt
Deutschland nicht alleine bewältigen
können wenn man sich mal anschaut ich
glaube wir tragen 0,2 dazu bei wenn man
es weltweit global sieht wenn jeder sagt
man kann das nicht allein ändern dann
wird sich überhaupt nichts ändern man
muss vorangehen man muss Akzente setzen
man muss genau hier in diesem Klima also
gegen den Klimawandel in eine
umweltfreundliche Energieform
investieren das ist die Zukunft alles
eine Angst vor einem Blackout ich habe
keine Angst vor einem fleckout geht
ihnen das auch so nein
selbstverständlich nicht aber zunächst
mal finde ich es ausgesprochen amüsant
dass sie als Sozialist sagen sie wollen
eine Rolle rückwärts vermeiden wir haben
genau
denn sie befürworten ja zum einen
Planwirtschaft und negieren zum anderen
die negativen Folgen dieser
planwirtschaftlichen Eingriffe wenn sie
sagen Wind Energie und Solarenergie
seien tatsächlich zuverlässige
Energieträger dann ist das ein objektiv
falsch es kann jeder sehen der einfach
mal versucht irgendetwas zu betreiben
wenn gerade kein Wind weht und die Sonne
nicht scheint das Problem sind die
Speicherkapazitäten das Problem ist auch
grundsätzlich auch bei Herrn Habeck das
Leute von Themen sprechen von denen sie
keine Ahnung haben die Netzlast muss ja
als Grundlast gehalten werden das heißt
es reicht nicht wenn wir da mal ein
bisschen mehr Wind und dann wieder ein
bisschen weniger haben sondern es muss
eine Grundlast geben und die Grundlast
kann entweder in der Tat über
Kernenergie funktionieren oder sie kann
über die saubersten und sichersten
Kraftwerke überhaupt jedenfalls in ihrem
Segment nämlich über die Deutschen
braun- und Steinkohle funktionieren wir
haben beispielsweise Abstand die
saubersten selbstverständlich was sie
doch gerade mit einem solchen Kurs
betreiben ist aber brauchen
Kohlekraftwerke muss man ja schon als
schmutzigen Stromproduzent bezeichnen
also schmutziger Stromproduzent
ohne Filter wie es zum Beispiel der
Volksrepublik China betrieben wird oder
in der DDR betrieben wurde wir haben
nicht umsonst
Schlager mit deutschen Kohlekraftwerken
über Jahrzehnte gehabt die Technologie
ist auf der ganzen Welt eingesetzt
worden wird heute auch noch genauso
gebaut beispielsweise in Afrika ja was
wir jetzt hier erreichen mit der
Deindustrialisierung denn die deutsche
Industrie lebt ja seit seit dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg davon dass wir günstigen Strom
überall gleichermaßen zuverlässig
verfügbar machen können
einhaken weil die Strompreise waren noch
nie günstig in Deutschland die wurden
auch immer subventioniert
genau
mit Steuern belegt deswegen es war nie
also es war nie Deutschland hatte nie
als Industriestandort den Vorteil die
niedrigsten Strom und Gaspreise zu haben
sondern von jetzt künstlich hohen und
jetzt haben wir die höchsten weltweit
wir haben es geschafft die
Aluminiumindustrie im Wesentlichen aus
Deutschland zu verdrängen wie im Moment
der wesentliche Jobmotor an ganz ganz
vielen Stellen war der Automobilbau der
geht gerade auch den Bach runter an
allen Stellen ich verstehe nicht die
Menschen glauben gerade auch in
Wirtschaftsminister glaubt wie das
eigentlich funktionieren soll denn all
das Geld das umverteilt werden muss ist
eben es wird nicht neu gedruckt es wird
auch nicht einfach als virtuelle
Geldmenge erhöht sondern es muss
erwirtschaftet werden vorausgesetzt es
soll noch ein Wert behalten und da sind
wir dann eben halt bei dem Thema der
Inflation auch die ist eine Folge dieser
desolaten planwirtschaftlichen